all right Rachel
Rachel which grew up where are you from
originally Houston Texas Houston tell me
about your family did both your parents
grown up no just had my mom who was an
alcoholic and would beat us every day
like
bad beat us like you know throw glass
bottles at my head
um
just whenever she felt like it
uh had a stepdad who got her to be an
alcoholic and he would put his hands on
us push us in the walls like you know
um
and then I was raped by my
brother-in-law
and my sister was in the same bed
she
apparently didn't notice it or whatever
but and she doesn't talk to me now
because she thinks I'm lying about it
and all that but
I was uh at five years old I was
molested by an uncle
and my mom thought it was weird that I
came home with like hickeys on my neck
but didn't think to think anything of it
um
she kicked me out at 13 for having a
girlfriend
and
since then I was just you know trying to
stay at friends houses and so on so
forth got into doing slamming Crystal
um
whenever I started slamming Crystal and
hanging out with that crowd I ended up
getting knocked out in the back of my
head or knocked in the back of my head
knocked out left on the train tracks
raped and I woke up to the train
literally from me to you
and only enough time to literally just
roll off and like cover my ears and
scream because it was so loud
um
if it weren't for the train horns I
wouldn't have woken up I would have been
dead by now
that's the reason why I came out here
is to get rid like get away from all
that
came out here to live with my sperm
donor who I met when I was 10.
um
five months with living with him he
ended up like trying to you know touch
me and all that and then whenever I like
forcefully said no he put his hands on
me and beat me
[Music]
um
like left me in a puddle of old milk
that he pushed me into the shelf and it
fell on me and everything and just left
me there
and I like when he left I I ran out like
I left and I've been on the streets in
California since then how old are you
now I'm 26. you've been homeless for how
long
since I was 13. it's 13.
you ran away no my mom kicked me out
well
you had a hell of a childhood yeah
yeah but it just makes you stronger I
guess
like now nothing phases me really I've
pretty much been through it all I've
like since being out here in California
I've been kidnapped by a gang
they raped me and beat me
um
I like that
yeah that that really [ __ ] with me
um
just recently I was beat the [ __ ] out of
by a you know female crew members of a
gang
um
for literally just asking if a pregnant
woman was okay who was a gang member
um and they stripped me of all my stuff
[ __ ] took everything everything
including my dog food
I was shooting heroin before I started
shooting Fentanyl
and now I just shoot fetty and uh shoot
Crystal
but where do you stay now where do I say
now
down literally like four streets from
where we are right now I don't know the
names of the streets are you gonna
attend yeah yeah
a little two-person tent right now
because our other one got stolen
but how do you support yourself
um well
to get my fix and [ __ ] I [ __ ] for it
um sometimes I Panhandle
uh because I'm not too good at boosting
anymore I used to boost like a lot like
really well but yeah the stores are
around to you guys now yeah and like and
they get hit numerous of times so
they're always like expecting it
and uh I'm more of a sneaky type of
booster like I saw that way I can come
back to the store rather than just Smash
and grab
but yeah so
it's a hell of a life you're living now
yeah are you uh affected emotionally by
all this you got to be yeah I've got
PTSD like I can't even hear a train horn
in the back like in the distance of any
sort without like having an anxiety
attack
um
yeah like it took me probably
the five months that I was staying with
my sperm donor to actually be able to
leave the house without anybody like
because I wouldn't even go down on the
steps and smoke a cigarette by myself
outside I had to have somebody there
with me
um
but yeah it took me about five months to
fully be able to leave and go to a store
by myself I wouldn't go anywhere at
night
I wouldn't go anywhere without my knife
or my pepper spray or anything
um
and if I was anywhere by like walking
anywhere by myself I have to had
somebody on the phone with me
because yeah and then just living out on
the streets in like San Francisco and
out here
so many times have I had where before I
got my dog
um where people would just watch me
sleep in my tent
and I'd wake up to them and like they'd
run off or like you know they'd flip my
[ __ ] over and like try to distract me
from you know trying to kick their ass
[Music]
yeah
you have any friends no no you tend to
not have friends out here right I have a
family you have no family either the
only family I did have was my sperm
donor out here and he's a piece of [ __ ]
who I don't even talk to anymore
and my mom
she's like trying to be in recovery
so she's like a full-fledged bible
thumper when she's not full-fledged
alcoholic raging
and I talk to her every now and then
like just to you know to let her know
I'm not dead because if I go like a
couple months without talking to her she
like
answers the phone crying thinking I'm
dead
um
yeah no friends are not a thing out here
people are not you don't trust people
and you learn that real quick like real
quick
you let them know anything about you and
it's
it's just ammo for them to be able to
get get at you somehow
your childhood seems so rough did you
feel loved at all as a kid
by my grandma your grandmother yeah my
grandma was my rock
she's dead now
but yeah
do you have kids I have one
he's back in Texas with uh my baby
daddy's mom
and
yeah I left him whenever he was about
six months old
because of the PTSD I didn't want to
like you know have him see me dead on
the floor and [ __ ]
or not PTSD but um postpartum
and uh
I left for a month at first with some
dude that I didn't even know
and then got on crystal
came back tried to try it again and then
I just ended up leaving putting myself
on child support
and
try to keep in touch try to do the mom
thing but I just I couldn't I that's
when I got into Crystal and got too
[ __ ] up
so I haven't seen my son in about almost
a year now
I think
and he's about six years old now
what's your biggest fear what do you
worry about now
surviving another [ __ ]
attempt at life to kill me like having
to go through it again having to
remember it all over again like I just
the one thing I can't wrap my head
around is the train incident why the
[ __ ] did I survive it
why the [ __ ] do I have to remember any
of that everything was coming at you
full speed or 100 yeah yeah like 100
full speed like I was like in nothing
but my ripped up panties and
like draped I was like my back over the
railings
and um
whenever I like came to I was hearing
the horn and I look up and I see the
like the train light like literally like
not even
I don't even know how long but like from
the carpet to carpet away from me and
that was just enough time for me to
actually roll off the train track and
just like like kind of try to you know
hold my ears shut without having to
[ __ ]
you know hear all that
and then I screened help and [ __ ] and
then the cops had me on a 72 hour hold
because they think I was crazy
and they wouldn't even like they said it
wasn't
that they're not going to declare at a
rate because I had to wash my fingers
like the dirt from underneath my nails
and stuff because I felt so dirty I had
so much like just dirt and stickers and
like sticks and [ __ ] all in my hair and
like dirt all over my body and [ __ ] I
just needed to feel clean somewhat and
so I washed my hands and so they didn't
even do a like a a test or whatever it's
called like a raped kit they didn't even
do that because of me washing my hands
so
the guys out there just running around
do you have any
good experiences in your life any
anything positive is that this happened
not really no not that I can think of
I mean just recently I started feeling
like maybe maybe I didn't want to die
but
have you been suicidal
I've had five suicide attempts fails
um
for some like for numerous reasons why
they failed like either somebody walked
in on me whenever I had the door locked
and somehow they were able to walk in
um if I like
you know it's like through all the pills
in my mouth that one time I ended up
throwing them all up and not being able
to do it
um
my best friend would like she texted me
and called me out of nowhere whenever I
was trying to do it and telling her
everybody goodbye and whatnot and like
she just was like are you okay and it
like her talking to me stopped me from
doing it
um
but yeah now I just
I feel like I just can't take myself out
so it's going to just happen regardless
somehow some way
eventually
and yeah
so
no good
like moments in my life honestly that I
can think of
except leaving getting like getting out
of my household
not being not having to be there no more
it was really pretty good
your biological dad
he does dope he does Crystal and you
know all that and he tried to molest me
and [ __ ] like that whenever I came out
here the first time I didn't meet him
until I was 10.
yeah and
yeah
he just he couldn't see me as a daughter
he just could not help himself to just
try to you know sexually touch me and
[ __ ] like that
we do acid together and he would try to
touch me and
it just yeah it wasn't
it wasn't a father symbol
so
you feel like life is unfair
very very very very unfair
he seem to get the short end of the
stick with every relationship you have
yeah and what's funny is that
I still believe that
evil in this world can't like it's not
gonna win you know I mean like the light
is going to win you still believe in
good
yeah I still believe that there's still
some good somewhere and like in order to
beat the evil we've got a
lead by example with the light you know
like
somebody told me well why'd you go and
do that for them they wouldn't have done
it for you
but okay but because I did it for them
now they'll you know they'll see that
some there is still somebody out there
that cares for just any human being
and they'll hopefully they'll show it to
another and then so on so forth
because we can't keep showing evil and
expecting evil not to win I mean
you still have hope that's that's
amazing yeah
there's got to be a reason why I'm here
what emotion do you go through most is
it anger or
more sad depression yeah
just like
everything
I think about like all throughout the
day I have to think about everything
that I've gone through and I have to
relive everything in my head
so I mainly just I'm I'm mainly sad
all the time
it's rare if I get to actually laugh
genuinely laugh
I'm doing dates with guys strangers is
not
yeah it's more like autopilot I just
you know
I do what I know and just
hope to God that I'm able to walk out of
there
and that what kind of money do you
charge here in Skid Row for sex
like 50
for everything
it's not much but yeah
it's enough to at least get some fetty
and get me well throughout the night
the guys have got to be horrible
yeah
but at least I don't have a pimp
I thank God that at least I don't
like you know have the whole pimp thing
going on because
I could never wrap my head around
a man owning my body telling me what to
do with who to do it with you know I
mean like
like they don't have the vagina so how
the hell are they making the rules
so at least I can choose who I want to
you know have a date with or who I don't
that's a perk do you feel betrayed by
your caregivers when you're a kid
yeah and I feel like
like my mom she because she was a good
mom Once Upon a Time like when we were
hella young like whenever I was like
five
like before I was five she wasn't an
alcoholic
um she like had like set days for us to
you know spend one of the days with one
of the kids
I would have like I had Friday and it
was makeup Friday
um she would do my makeup and I do hers
and then we'd take pictures and you know
but after that like that was like the
last good memory I have with my mom
before it just
she couldn't control
herself on alcohol like she was running
from her past the [ __ ] up [ __ ] that
she had happened to her
and ran to alcohol and then did you know
your mom's story is what she went
through as a kid yeah my my grandfather
was very very very abusive to the point
to where like he would slam my
grandmother's hand arm in the car door
um
like he would he fixed my mom's brakes
to where they like they got cut
um
like
in order for like for their chores and
stuff around the house she had to do
dishes in a scolding hot water because
he was Air Force so military you know so
he made them do everything that they had
to do and like on the camp and [ __ ]
and um
yeah she just she was never able to like
wrap her head around any of that and
come to closure with any of it so
alcohol was her go-to
and it made her become the same person
that her father was so
not too far from it
the OD'd and fennel before
like twice
um somebody had a Narcan meeting twice
the nasal Narcan I think
um
God damn that shit's [ __ ] horrible
like the worst feeling I think I've ever
felt in my life savior's life though
yeah I don't know if that's a good thing
or not
but
I mean like I guess I thank them now
because it was my boyfriend at the time
I thank them now for doing it because
you know
that would be very [ __ ] ungrateful to
not thank somebody for saving your life
but
I literally just wanted to die whenever
I was going through the precipitated
withdrawals like it was the worst pain
I've ever felt and I couldn't just go
fix it and get high and then not feel
that I had to go through it for like
eight hours
before it finally stopped
and it sucked
you you live this less than ideal life
for pretty much your entire existence
yeah do you feel like you're you'd be
even capable of
living a life where maybe you had
you know a great partner a nice house a
car a job kids you know you know
everything in
you know white picket fence and all that
you think you'd be able to even be able
to adjust to that
I want that like so badly I like I just
to be indoors again would be
just insanely happy for me
I think that would be the best thing in
my life is just getting to be inside
again
I miss washing my face three times or
two times a day and taking a shower
whenever I wanted to going to the
bathroom whenever I want to
like
dressing up just to go out for the night
uh going to a bar for the night you know
like
I really want that I miss that life
like
bad
um but
I know I won't ever have the white
picket fence but I know like if I can at
least get indoors which is what I'm
working on now my housing if I can at
least get an apartment
I will be more than happy with that like
you know I mean like just in
be able to lock a door and not have to
have anybody worry about anything yeah
you know like I'm on my like 10th ID
replacement I think
like my birth documents I've had to get
uh you know duplicates like three times
already and that's
yeah maybe on clothes that are yours
rather than hand-me-downs maybe own
clothes that are yours rather than just
hand-me-downs right exactly or whatever
I find out like you know out on the
street or whatever I've had body lice so
many times I can't count I stopped
[ __ ] picking [ __ ] up off the ground
to where
um like it's just yeah
that was stupid I mean they even do in
the first place
especially down here knowing how dirty
it is down here I [ __ ] I picked up
clothes down here to where like without
washing it or anything or even like hand
washing it
yeah and I found out real quick what you
get and the lights out here is insane
it's not like
like they die with heat
you can catch them on fire and it
[ __ ] lives it's they're like
Invincible it's [ __ ] crazy
it's insane
and the Rats oh my God they're the size
of my dog
have you tried to quit fentanyl
when I got arrested I kicked it
um in Santa Rita in jail yeah I kicked
it uh because I was in there for a week
and a half how horrible is that
hmm
the precipitated withdrawals were way
worse but it was still bad like I
I tried sleeping through it but I
couldn't sleep I was Restless throwing
up
constipated and then diarrhea
but at least there I had a bathroom I
could use at any point I needed to
so
but like day five is whenever I finally
felt kind of semi-normal and was able to
actually go out and get something to eat
whenever it was time to you know go get
food
but yeah it still sucked like horribly
bad
and I can't I can't believe I ever
I mean fentanyl is completely better
like with the sickness the dopes it is
completely better than tar heroin
heroin's dope stick was oh my [ __ ]
God I couldn't even
if I went to sleep for three hours and I
woke up without it like you know not
doing a shot or nothing immediately I
woke up crying because of how bad my
body hurt I'd have to do a shot
instantly
with Betty it's
mainly just sniffles for the first like
12 hours and then after that it's like
you know restless legs but by then you
usually have had a hit by then you know
I mean
[Music]
um
I know I definitely don't want to be
slamming drugs at least very much any
longer I'd like to just be able to just
smoke it
because I don't even catch a nod like I
don't nod off or nothing with slamming
it like there's no high anymore it's
crazy it's just it's just something you
need yeah it's just to make myself feel
normal again
what do you think most people don't
outside of the drug lifestyle what do
you think most people don't understand
about drug addiction
that is actually something you need
after four times of doing it
consecutively like if you do it four
days in a row
you can't just not do it like you seem
very intelligent you're CA you you
understand that doing drugs is bad yeah
you have a kid you have another life
you'd like to live but yeah it's just
impossible to stop
it's my way of escaping everything and
not having to think of everything
because like two years ago whenever I
first started Fentanyl
all I had to do was do like 10 little
units
and then like do that in a shot and I
instantly out without the for the rig
ever left my arm like I'd you know go
out for hours and
that was that was perfect like that's
why I needed to escape my brain from you
know thinking about everything
but now it's just maintaining trying to
feel normal and working all day you know
doing things I don't want to do just to
[ __ ] feel normal again it sucks
but kicking it's even worse
so
it's like a lose-lose
unless you make it through the [ __ ]
the kick
and in order to do that you have to have
kind of a substitute really like
Crystal or something something else to
do you need another
addiction or Obsession or something but
it's a just a losing Circle
constantly
how do you think all these years on the
street living this life has changed you
before I came out here
whenever I was living back in Texas
I had a
at a home girl who was like a Daddy's
Money type girl you know she had a
beamer and she'd go to the bar every
night and well she took me in and uh
like
for a little while there it was like my
daddy's money type thing where like I
was driving her Beamer around we were
going to the bar every night [ __ ]
dressing like you know to attend
uh bringing guys back if we wanted to
selling crystal for like all over Austin
um and like my head was so in the clouds
then that's why I didn't realize what
was going to happen to me was going to
happen
and then so looking at that and then
looking at who I am now I would never
even stepped foot in Skid Row if I were
still the person I was then
I wouldn't even have picked anything up
off the ground any donation boxed
clothing I would have never touched
nothing
I would have never done any of the [ __ ]
that I do now
except the drugs I was still doing the
drug Zone that's whenever I was slamming
Crystal only who introduced you to drugs
at first
well
I was popping Xannies when I was in
seventh grade
like with the plug like he was my homie
in school and [ __ ] like that was just
a normal daily thing so honestly school
did
like and it just went from there because
then I started liking Norcos in high
school
skipping High School to [ __ ] you know
just pop some pills and just you know go
chill back at my place my adopted
parents
who were my friend's parents
um
my adopted mom or my like my friend's
parents they she had me selling her
Hydro her oxycodones
or oxycontins honestly sorry but had me
selling those at school for 30 a pill
so it's honestly it's just been in my
life all the time like
I was snorting Crystal before I was
filming it
is there anything you feel like you
could have done to
have avoided
this situation you're in now in your
life or is it there's too many things
that were stacked against you as a kid
I think it was too many things stacked
against me because I mean at five years
old I'm coming back with hickeys on my
neck
you know like
you're just trying to avoid the pain of
those memories yeah like I shouldn't I
life sucks completely bad and it's like
no matter what I do
to put good out there
it's just more negative that just gets
piled on me
like asking a pregnant woman if she's
okay
and to like calm down think of the baby
I get the [ __ ] beat out of me and with a
baseball bat to my head
like
that that don't make no sense well as
smart as you do with you being white
then probably anything else yeah
probably
so
being kidnapped by a gang I like all I
did was [ __ ]
I didn't have my tent set up with the
poles I just had like a tarp over my
stuff and I was sleeping
and I guess they told my boyfriend like
they wanted it to look nicer there so
for us to get a tent with poles by the
end of the day and I didn't know that
and
next thing I know we're getting our tarp
ripped off of us and the [ __ ] the
boss man's having one of his little
henchmen
you know tell us to leave and leave all
of our [ __ ] and I had to go and talk to
him and then he just he took me without
like my will like you know without my
okay like had his henchmen [ __ ] grab
me and you know throw me in the car and
[ __ ]
and I was like
I wasn't like with them for like a week
with them doing everything they did to
me until [ __ ] I was able to escape
and like just like you see what I mean
like I was doing nothing wrong I was not
bothering nobody I was just minding my
own business and I still had that happen
to me
like
if I would have been told if I were to
have been told to if I can go get an
actual tent I would have gotten a
[ __ ] tent you know I mean like I know
gangs don't I've been dealing with gangs
my whole life my cousin was a crit like
I've I know this [ __ ]
they don't play like if they say
something you do it because
they're not playing around they're not
just speaking to speak
Russia what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
mind your [ __ ] business
because like I used to think that seeing
a woman getting beat up on the side of
the street by some dude that that's not
right you know like I should go and
interfere like intervene to stop that
yeah I know
mind your business keep your [ __ ]
head down
don't
don't put yourself in situations you
don't have to be in because they can
they're a lot worse than you really
think
a lot worse
all right Rachel thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
lots of luck from here now thank you
thank you